les chiroux va passer au 100 pour 100 go
si je vous parlais de la sextape de kim
kardashian
oui mais elle fait toujours autant
parler c'est un truc de ouf 4 a fait une
sextape ici rohff a fait sur rov sinon
je trouverais ouais moi tu peux tout
dire non jamais marion non au nom avec
raymond la diaphane cheikhou diaby
tellement longtemps que je m'en souviens
plus
alors moi je sais qu'elle a fait un
roman photo l
isabelle ça lui fait un truc avec des
photos un peu
non moi non je rigole
j'ai fait des photos j'ai fais des
romans mais les deux ensembles jamais
pas personne personne n'a jamais fait de
sexe est ce que vous appelez secte et
bas se filmer en train de râler ya des
photos ça évidemment l'a tous fait avec
un téléphone oui mais c'est rigolo quand
on fait l'amour ce film est bien content
parce que c'est tout bête par exemple
comment vous vendez vous tiens vous
aimez un plan cul qui vous appelle est
ce que tu es chaud t na na na na pour
vous dire bah voilà optant voix la vidéo
pour montrer ce que tu sais faire mais
la visant à des plans sur une bande démo
[Rires]
pour les narcissiques c'est ce qu'aime
justement vous êtes jamais filmé vous
bougez il suffit polaroïd j'ai fait quoi
et des photos pour la rouille et
commence à vous étiez comme as oui au
bout du truc qu'on a pu ce truc et ça
sans rapeller attend que ça sorte et on
se voit non lieu son sexe au polaroïd
c'est une vision d'horreur mais là c'est
la maison du oui j'ai eu des moments
très gênant et oui justin bridou merci
qu est ce que beaucoup de photos de nus
de mon mari quand il était
particulièrement en forme et permet jeu
que j'ai dans son album photo et après
j'ai oublié un jour j'avais des amis à
la maison non des enfants et qui sont
tombées sur nos cadences rage de photos
de nus à l'horizon pour mon mari certes
mais quand même extravagant hui car
contrairement à ce que dit mathieu il en
a un est intéressant c'est qu'on sent
malheureux alors on y va c'est le 100%
possible on y va
et s'imposant 2-1
accepte de kim kardashian donc fait
toujours autant parler rock tu t'es déjà
filmé et bien oui sa défense mais on
appelle une sextape canton le diffusant
des raisons web est ce que vous êtes
déjà filmé comme servier mais quand on
est en couple et que ça fait longtemps
qu'on est content bien sûr on trouve des
petits soirée ça oui moi j'ai merdé
j'ai regardé j'ai regardé une fois -
boxe aux effets photo à l'époque on sent
et des photos de pas de peine film est
un film et des phonèmes je suis gêné de
dire des photos du sexe en fait et
j'avais fait le dernier texto que
j'avais envoyé c'est ma meuf et ma soeur
en deux groupes et bien que j'ai renvoyé
à ma mère et à ma soeur exprès parce que
j'avais une vie mais avant j'ai retapé
sur le groupe et ouvrir leurs fautes
parce que c'est en train de se chauffer
dans l'après-midi et moi j'ai pris ma
meuf en livraison livraison à l'aller
tout à fait digne on se chauffe en
gestion livraison dans le canal banon
met d'autant que le fléau et nouveau je
m'occupe le temps que les nouveaux ça